et maintenant mesdames messieurs
et
ayrton senna n'ont pas levé le manteau
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à bord
vous connaissez le rock et la mixité de
rien à cirer à la belle et paris dakar
vous êtes le petit fils du sculpteur
paul belmondo est le fils de l'acteur
jean-paul belmondo
d'accord
[Musique]
qui débarque et hic le foutoir avait
coûté à chacun son truc ce qu'elle aime
passer d'habitude on peut le savoir
donc vous êtes né en 1963 alors que
votre père faisait les dernières prises
de vue de l'homme de rio qui est
d'ailleurs le premier film de lui que
vous ayez vu c'est vrai c'est le 1er
juillet sur tout sujet le plus vu
j'aimerais voir chez pool adoré ça le
truc quoi j'ai passé mes copains tout le
temps alors votre père n'a jamais été
doublé dans ses films enfin je vous
refais des mauvaises langues disent que
vous êtes doublé c'est qu'on sait que
c'est une mauvaise vanne je suis désolé
mais je la connais je veux faire
communiquer mais ça m'arrive je sais
c'est pas comme si
je l'avais servir à la belle époque
effectivement j'avais dit c'est le
contraire de votre père lui au cinéma il
refusait de se faire doubler lui voue en
bagnole c'est tout le contraire c'est un
métier
vient alors le secret dans votre famille
c'est le sport celle que votre père il
fait toujours trois heures de sacs de
sable par jour fait toujours beaucoup de
sport quotidiennement tous les jours
grand-père est monté dans son atelier
avec une corde plutôt que de monter par
l'escalier comme si une famille vraiment
bien son atelier vous saviez pas ici son
grand père il montait à lodja de son
atelier de sculpture avec une corde tout
simplement que c'est des gens très
bizarre et vous donc très jeune j'ai été
obligé de faire du sport alors pas
obligé n'a pas obligé si quand même
parce que quand on voit tout ce que vous
avez fait honnêtement c'est vous avez
été surutilisés d'avoir grand-père déjà
été jugée
vous avez fait de la boxe du tennis du
ski nautique du vélo du foot la saison
de karting j'ai commencé le karting à 16
ans alors très jeune en fait cette
passionnée pas du tout par le cinéma
mais par l'automobile par les équipes de
formule 1 les écuries de formule 1 c'est
votre truc vous rencontrez grâce à votre
père beaucoup de beaucoup de grands
pilotes pironi la fille de jacky ickx
donc le 18 juin parce que toutes les
grandes choses arrivent à 1 18 juin le
18 juin 1977 est en vacances à rome vous
avez 14 ans il a dévoyé lafitte qui est
premier du grand prix de suède sur une
ligier mais j'ai aussi extraordinaire et
et vous dites moi aussi je piloterai une
formule 1
non mais j'étais passionné tout petit
depuis fin juin moi mais mes enfants ne
sont pas du tout passionné parfum au
même âge que je pensais qu'à ça c'est
pareil c'était en regardant la télé tout
petit j'ai vu thierry ardisson j je
serai
je faisais les missions que j'ai appelé
samedi soir à l'époque chez maxim's
car vous commencez par le volant elf
mais déjà posé des problèmes dus à votre
nom il a fallu deux passages pour vous
gagnez c'est à dire qu'en fait c'était
compliqué quoi en fait je l'avais gagnée
du premier coup je pense qu'à l'époque
le jury s'est dit si on laisse le fils
de belmondo gagner ça va faire mouche
donc ils m'ont fait passer une deuxième
fois et je les gagner une deuxième fois
ça a été très bien c'est au moins à
partir ce moment là j'ai compris
j'attends donc moi je veux dire chez lui
il a gagné qu'un volant tous les autres
filles du pognon il a eu le nom et qu'on
pensait tout passé à la formule renault
et là vous découvrez que pour être
pilote ben ça c'est du riquet il faut
s'acheter une conduite non
c'est pas du riz pied ça marche
fini les boîtes font plus
bon et après on formule 1 alors informez
vous apercevez comme c'est très cher ce
n'est pas que ça vous coûte et combien
coute combien de 18 millions de francs
par saison maintenant aujourd'hui à
l'époque n'ont heureusement ouais ça
coûte et combien à l'époque 92 j'avais
trouvé
3 millions de dollars pour faire de la
formule 1 puis quand 15 millions fait ça
faisait 15 millions à l'époque ouais et
puis beaucoup moins en 94 mais la
voiture était nettement moins bonne
alors j'ai appris en préparant cette
interview que sur par exemple 32 pilotes
il y en a que 6 6 7 8 qui sont payés et
les autres payent pour faire la course
s'est fait j'en paye pour conduire on a
beaucoup bien sûr un oui oui paye
directement via des sponsors eux où ils
sont imposés par une marque de moteur ou
de pneumatiques les choses comme ça et
en outre 92 est obligé d'abandonner la
saison malheureusement entamée parce que
c'était impossible quoi et en face de
vous des gens qui avaient beaucoup
d'argent comme ferrari comme mclaren
williams et dont vous êtes obligés
d'arrêter quoi en fait j'arrête surtout
parce que j'ai plus j'ai plus d'argent
pour financer ma saison alors je venais
de faire mon meilleur grand prix je n'ai
terminé neuvième du grand prix de
hongrie mais mes plus de sous donc
terminée quand même le fils de belmondo
fallait faire comme le fils d'alain
delon
leur garde à vue pendant la crise ce
sont neuf ans aurait pu tomber sur vous
ça tombe sur lui la fiche 69 donc c'est
les rôles sont inversés c'est simple
vous allez me pose une question vous
vous posez une question ou et allez-y je
m'attends à colas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous feriez pour rendre
les meulières plus intéressant à la télé
pour les molières plus intéressant ben
je les produire avec catherine barma
déjà ce qui amène ali serait une bonne
chose
ça lui va bien très bien parce qu'il dit
molière c'est tu ne regardes
vous connaissez ça
[Applaudissements]
chez gaston qui va donner merci
l'instant
bravo il s'appelle honneur et obtenir
une star une star mais même là george
marshall en a parlé
omar m'a tuer
bon alors donc après la formule 1 vous
allez en gt c'est à dire en grand
tourisme qu'étant le 31 août 97 ans fiat
uno sous le
nom
donc j'étais il ya un championnat du
monde c'est un truc est en plein essor
enfin champion du monde depuis 97 ya
ferrari à lamborghini et donc je vis une
écurie qui s'appelle paul belmondo
racing vous étaient deuxièmes
championnats du monde en l'an 2000 ouais
ça marche on a fait une très bonne année
donc c'est une bonne chose mais au moins
je sais où va mon argent dont tu peux un
foot moins cher que la formule 1 la
série n'avoir rien à voir combien à peu
près pour voir le budget qu'on a cette
année pour trois voitures avec les 24
heures du mans va être de l'ordre de 17
millions de francs près réglée non mais
une saison de formule 1 aujourd'hui on
parle de 900 millions voire un milliard
de froid alors votre objectif ces
championnats du monde par équipe est
championne du monde des pilotes et la
première course importante c'est à spa
le 29 juillet maintenant on va
s'intéresser à ça maintenant qu on vous
connaît oui mais si retransmis à la télé
ça certes ensuite pour eurosport toutes
les courses retransmises en direct les
essais aussi c'est ce que votre père
vient pardon quand vous faites des
courses il a hélas pas le mois de
juillet il vient mais il vient pas
toutes les courses ça dépend de six
tours nous parle donc mais il vient à
venir il vous a aidé votre père beaucoup
non mon père m'a aidé et m'a aidé par sa
notoriété il m'a aidé par ses relations
il a aidé financièrement
secrétaire il a mis sa secrétaire à
disposition dans ses bureaux ils vous
aident encore votre père aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui non ils m'aident ils mettent
par sa part sa notoriété jury lorsque
c'était mon père vient en mode jour la
présentation de mon écurie il est
évident il y aura plus de presse il est
là que si les voilà donc pas sa
notoriété il met beaucoup toujours bien
sûr alors il ya un truc avec vous qui
est très bizarre c'est que vous dites je
n'ai jamais cru que j'étais un surdoué
du volant je suis un peu un besogneux je
ne serai jamais prost ou senna je ne
serai jamais super alors pourquoi
continuer pourquoi quand on est le fils
de jean paul belmondo encore maître jean
alesi
pourquoi non pas parce que vous risquez
votre vie dimanche après midi sur des
sur des routes d une femme et des
enfants parés patient à patient aux les
raisons point qu'elle aussi j'ai créé
une écurie si aujourd'hui pendant
quelques années arrêté et continuer à
vivre à vivre cette passion à travers ça
mais c'est la passion qui fait qu' on
fait ce métier ou concours vraiment sa
chance et j'étais aussi talentueux que
ça je serai toujours en formule 1 ouais
fair même en sachant vous serez jamais
eu ni ayrton senna ni ça vous dérange
pas vous continuez quand même non ça ne
dérange pas
chaque saison du championnat de france
de football il ya dix huit équipes s'il
y en a que quatre qui vont gagner le
championnat enfin au cinéma vous avez
fait un rôle important qui était donc le
fils de votre père à 25 ans dans les
linéaires de l'enfant gâté c'est à dire
que il s'en dit rajeunir belmondo ça va
être compliqué donc il vous en prie vous
ouais et dans les misérables aussi dans
les misérables aussi j'ai des gens
valjean jeune shoshanna box ont crié
papa tu as
mon rôle est arrêté on nous demande
demande manque plus maintenant de rennes
je demande que c'était
aux vieux vous dites c'est bizarre je
suis un peu comme le fils du boucher qui
aurait voulu être cordonnier c'est à
dire que les gens vous en veulent ne pas
avoir fait du cinéma vous pensé non non
non je pense je pense pas comme on veut
je crois que c'est juste dans l'image
sans que si j'avais commencé par faire
du cinéma s'arrêtait plus facile au
début après talent pour continuer comme
dans tout dans la vie chacun qui
il n'ya pas de triche mais je crois que
dans les gens sentaient plus logiques
d'acteurs comme son père c'est que le
petit est vide et il a fait de la
chanson le petit dolan et la fête du
cinéma et tout le monde s'étonne que
vous fassiez pas du cinéma c'est vrai
mais peut-être demain je ferai du cinéma
ouais la marque et vous devez la gueule
alors en revanche j'ai très très bien
réussi votre vie conjugale alors ça a
commencé
salut ma
position est pas une position ça a
commencé une façon un peu violente
c
donc au début c'était un ouragan pour
faire oublier ses trucs heureusement que
je suis là je suis la mémoire de ce pays
madame messieurs
après vous avez trouvé la femme idéale
d'ailleurs ça se passe très très bien
non pas super nôtre il faut la nuit mais
c'est avec elle que
pour avoir
lu anna qui vous a été présenté
d'ailleurs par par anthony delon
et italiennes et ça c'est vrai que les
italiennes déjà quand elle parle c'est
gagner quoi non
mais c'est vrai
qu'elle me murmure dans l'oreille en
italien c'est gagner moi très bien non
moi je ne peux pas résister tout moi je
vous dis tout de suite
c'était mission maintenant qui réplique
de son ampleur c'est la fureur et voilà
arthur et alors
il ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
vous me rappelez dangereusement laurent
baffie c'est terrible on la comprend 58
chez 3com accompli non il bourg le
gymnase en ce moment c'est vrai et bah
oui
alors je vous faire une hardy view
vous pensez à quoi la halle 1
à la question est posée sur stéphanie de
monaco
j'ai réveillé dans la mémoire de paul
belmondo le souvenir monsieur stéphane
it avec un directeur de cirque en ce
moment mais ses passagers au chant du
compte je n'ai pas le temps c'est
non je pensais que j'avais pas le temps
de répondre en fait ouais ça vous est
posée action heureuse et mis en musique
mais j'ai pas pu dire
c'est bien la mort vous aviez 20 ans est
même plus jeune que ça ouais c'est ça 18
ans vous saviez pas ce que vous faisiez
j'étais en principauté
alors messieurs
[Applaudissements]
non inscription de toute façon bien sûr
voilà une erreur de jeunesse dont
annonce n'est pas une erreur non
maintenant pourquoi ce serait une erreur
bah je sais pas si j'ai bien compris
elle fait l'annuaire des métiers
n'ont jamais fait le matin quand vous
voyez dans le miroir vous dites quoi je
demande encore
si je vais me raser au pas me raser
ouais verdi tu fais du baffie
voulais ressembler à qui quand vous
étiez petit
quand j'étais petit je parle carlos
pacheco jacky sous jeudi soir jackie
stewart vous avez le quid de robbie
williams sur jackie stewart bien énorme
perte énorme bien ce qui vous énerve le
plus chez vous en vous
en moi
je pars au caractère
caractère faisait mauvais caractère
mauvais je peux ouais ouais je retire
tout ce que j'ai dit
ce qui vous énerve le plus chez moi en
moi en vous
rien merci et chez ruquier ce qui nous
énerve sur le quai
sylviane rien non non vous êtes bon
caractère ouais le faux culs
vous vous aimez quoi quand on vous
demande des autographes paul belmondo
oui c'est tout m'était pas amicalement
vôtre si vous habitiez si les genres
ajoute jean
aux québécois mouton qu'on me demande
des autographes comment vous écrivez
quoi quand on vous demande des
autographes a très vite
gros bisous de tout coeur
[Musique]
voilà vous avez pleuré quand pour la
dernière fois
il n'a pas souvent non non ti peut-être
la naissance à naissance de mon fils
vous changeriez qu en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
j'ai une baguette magique
on arrête on s'énerve c'est un flingue
pour changer en ayrton senna maintenant
rim est là qui vient de tomber de la
part de stéphanie de haine il dit il à
une baguette magique
si c'était à refaire votre vie vous
referiez quoi pas pareil
rien voilà tout pareil non je pense que
il ya toujours des choses qu'on regrette
mais je crois qu'il faut pas faut pas
lire été à ce point là pour y être
prince héritier de monaco je pourrais
vraiment c'est vrai non merci alors ça
ça ne serait pas drôle pourquoi attendez
si une cage dorée il yad abord si vous
pensez que c'est un mauvais job tu
parles tu finis avec une [ __ ] au bord
d'une piscine
sincèrement sincèrement c'est pardon ah
ouais à l'époque je pense je enfin je
pensais pas ça mais aujourd'hui quand je
regarde la manière dont leur vie et
divulguées dans la presse ce qu'on dise
qu'on fait
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas de vie non non
ça ça nous dans la bresse et toujours
des photos très bien et qu anna les
enfants dans le c'est vrai c'est
vachement mieux bien chez nous moi aussi
j'ai bien géré les autres ne voient pas
non
qui avez-vous le plus envie d'épater
pas épaté si je n'aime pas le terme
épaté parce que mes
je pense que j'ai envie c'est de
de faire plaisir mes enfants de leur
montrer que ce que je fais a de la
valeur mais j'ai pas envie d'épater le
côté pat
smtc frime un peu le péché qui vous
tente le plus le péché qui me tente le
plus à l'agencé al ala attention lula
n'a tu peux aller chercher une bière
dans le frigo
non il n'y a rien ou ne veut pas faire
un excès de vitesse très rapidement tri
des sachets ya pas longtemps vous
pourrez y est géniale qui se lâche et
puis des mecs bien évidemment l'arête et
tout ça c'est même pas sur un circuit c
n'ont même pas
vous engueuler parce qu'il aura lie avec
votre valeur m avait ébloui et où vous
êtes engagés n'ont pas arrêté exemple à
savoir la photo sûrement ah oui j'avais
pas très vite dans toutes vos photos
sont pas non plus très bien gérée en
colère
quand le téléphone sonne vous êtes
heureux ou agacé ça n'est pas inquiet
lors
du cac et là on peut vous appeler
ça c'est plutôt ma femme à l'italienne
donc
certaines heures faut plus appeler elle
vous sert
tiennent donc s'est occupé toujours
comme l'italienne c'est ben salah ben
ammar sa dernière question paul belmondo
faut-il être quelqu'un
on
sent qu'il veut prendre la place à pivot
l'humain
paul belmondo
prochaine cause dont deux masters
juillet à spa
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux